as College continues to get more
expensive some students are choosing to
learn a trade such as Plumbing or
carpentry instead tonight 8 news now
education reporter Joshua piguero looks
at how for some people a degree just
doesn't make Financial sense
[Music]
Mikhail Jones wasn't happy with his job
after graduating from basic high school
I didn't really know what to do as a
career I was working in the kitchen
originally before I was like a prep cook
and dishwasher he knew College wasn't
for him so the 23 year old instead
enrolled at the National Technical
Institute and now he works as an
engineer at Lake Las Vegas
before just never be able to like afford
college and stuff like that so I pretty
much just went to trade school which is
more affordable data from the national
student Clearinghouse shows an eight
percent drop in college enrollment from
2018 to 2022. the electrical program is
one of three that students can do here
at NTI they get Hands-On training and
they're able to get their certificate in
four months or less NTI charges students
between six thousand and nine thousand
dollars depending on whether they study
HVAC Plumbing or electrical right now
there's enough momentum that people are
starting to realize there's a huge
employment gap and when the pandemic
happened people were looking for
essential jobs there are students
enrolled here that are switching careers
at 40 years old Nolan Cordero made a
leap of faith learning HVAC he says his
previous job was back breaking chainsaw
work cutting wood I mean it's good money
but eventually your body can only last
so long but for students who have not
yet graduated college there are several
Clark County magnet schools including
Northwest Korean Tech Academy that teach
kids construction trades while in high
school reporting in Henderson Joshua
preguero eight news now despite college
enrollment going down recently U.S
census data shows there were 13 million
more Americans with a bachelor's degree
in 2021 than there were in 2011.